adolf hitler might be the highest
performance guy that
ever was born on the planet bill gates
does not
chill he does not go to the super bowl
why do you externs is not a single act
it's a habit
find somebody that is where you want to
be 20 or 30 years from now
and go to him or her now
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation top 10
all my life
he's dan pena and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success volume 4.
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one surround yourself with greatness
the first method for estimating the
intelligence of a ruler is to look at
the man he surrounds himself with now
if i were going to judge you or you or
you
by the guys you hang with the guys you
chill with i think you're a [ __ ]
you hang into bill gates does not chill
he does not go to the super bowl
steve jobs didn't hang
why do you
you hang out with monkeys a lot of
resemblance here
you know you become a circus show me
your friends and i'll show your future
most of you would be embarrassed to tell
me who your
five closest buddies are rule number two
minimize your regrets i didn't know i
had this in common with the founder of
amazon but he's in the regret
minimization business
he is modeled his life styled
what will i regret when i'm 80. now that
he's 50-something he says now it's going
to be 90. same as me
but i've had 80 for a long long time
and there's still some things this i
have three regrets
one i'm a combat trained uh army officer
they never saw
combat two um
that the day before my mother died at
here at the castle
i'm screaming out god damn it don't be a
[ __ ] you're not sick you're not gonna
die
next morning she's dead go back on that
can you
and the third is i didn't set my goals
high enough
nothing about missing my son or my
daughter's sweet 16
or missing a soccer or a baseball game
no none of that
that you have been led to believe
wrongfully are important
i am a world-class eulogy griever
and every single person i've buried i
normally go to see them but
normally they ask me before they die i
go and i said well what do you
you know what do you want me to say
and they always say oh i'm sorry for it
i didn't take this risk
i didn't do this i didn't do that not
that i missed my son's wedding
not that i miss my third grandchild's
birth
all that sloppy sloppy sh
it's the risk they didn't take rule
number three be a high performer
adolf hitler might be the highest
performance guy that
ever was born on the planet
he got being high performance doesn't
mean you're a good guy
he got more done with less than any
human being ever
he got more done with less a little
chicken
private uh austrian from the second
world war
to be chancellor of the fatherland
so i mean when i say it i mean it's a
compliment not all the bad things he did
but i mean from from some nothing to
something
he's a high performance guy rule number
four press the envelope
i am mostly titanium and steel parts
this is me
artificial shoulders artificial
collarbone artificial knees full knees
artificial hip i've been busted up over
the years
i do a lot of extraordinary things
not the least of which getting run over
by a buffalo 25 years ago
but i'm always pressing the envelope
physically
and mentally and financially
i.e we started the boxing ring which uh
as i told some of you in the beginning
95 percent of everybody thought it was a
great idea five percent said that i was
inhumane like the gladiators and the
lions and all kind of [ __ ]
and i've continued to press myself
now this is a 2014 we're in new zealand
and i'm i i see a poster about um bungee
jumping
and i said sally i got to do that and
sally says turn around and
it's right here this is where the bungee
dumps so i got to do that so
the next morning i'm in line there's
about 50 60 millennials kind of like you
guys
and they're all saying the winds were
gusting 40 to 60 miles an hour
and you can't jump so all the
millennials will go when that
wind dies down i'm going to jump that
i'm going to jump
they're all dancing around so i wait
about ten minutes
i take a hundred dollar bill i walk up
to the head of the line
i said don't you think that the wind's
died down now
he said i believe it is has sir i jump
okay i come back these guys are still
saying went out
well did you jump uh i didn't know the
wind died down
but when it dies down the next time i'm
gonna jump
i believe with all my heart some of
those guys are still in line waiting
also if you want to have confidence like
dan pena check out my 254 confidence
series it's free the link is in the
description below
but no one does know initially up front
you have to try you have to swing at the
plate a kid like you
if you had to keep track of seven days a
week 24
hours a day what you do rule number five
find
mentors you only have one time to make a
first impression
the first impression is how you look now
i already know how i look
and you know how i look as well second
impression is
when you open your mouth most of you
with the greatest respect
uh can't speak properly
you stutter you mumble you sweat
and i can go on and on i've learned to
like the hot lights because i want to
convey my message
so you go where there are people that
you want to be like you find somebody
that is
in my whole basis is mentorship find
somebody that is where you want to be
20 or 30 years from now and
go to him or her now and
i had the the presence of mine to be
attracted to some very very famous
very well wealthy people in my 50-year
career
and i went after them to not not for
money
not for anything like that but i just
wanted them to talk to me and to share
their wisdom rule number six
build good habits excellence is not a
single act it's a habit
and right now most of you have pissed
poor habits
and most of the kids on youtube have
piss-poor habits
because your habits have been based on
what you've seen
first of all how your parents acted
second of all
how um your the people that you've been
exposed to
hanging with show me your friends and
i'll show you a future
and um the um if you uh
in your neighborhood you know most of
the kids are getting arrested going to
jail
going to prison there's a high
probability that you're going to get
arrested and you're going to go to jail
and you're going to go to prison
rule number seven take action what are
you going to tell your children
what are you going to tell your
grandchildren 20 years from now
daddy grandpa what were you doing during
the greatest transformation of wealth in
the history of the
planet other than having your thumb up
your ass
what are you going to tell them oh i was
thinking about it i was spreading it
i'm proud to say i haven't done a
spreadsheet in 10 15 years
go read another book
go listen to another read a blog listen
to a podcast
rule number eight want it bad enough
there's a hip-hop
motivational guy a black guy um
yeah and he says if if you don't want to
be successful as much as you want lung
breath in your lungs
now you qualify in this room hardly
anybody that comes to the seminar
qualifies
when i was doing this and when i
invented qla
and didn't know it was qla at the time i
only knew it was qla when i look back
and i put it together the model if you
will or the formula
i wanted it more than air
i sacrificed my god my country
my family my children my parents
my friends and guess what
it happened rule number nine be an eagle
eagles fly alone i have no friends
friends are problems friends are
challenges
if you can if you aren't into yourself
and that means something else now than
what i mean if you're not into yourself
enough that you can't spend the weekend
by yourself
then you're something's wrong with you
vis-a-vis
self-esteem being a high-performance
person and accomplishing high
performance
acts something's wrong with you and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is dream big from a
guy i was a barrio bad boy
in the body of east los angeles to
the guthrie that's a big leap
that's a big big it doesn't
i can't imagine well came close last
year i was uh
honored by the queen of england i
am now as they call a member of st
john a member of st
john which is just thank you
thank you and it's it it's a derivative
of the templar
the people that supposedly took christ's
body da da da
and you know the knights of the templar
that's what it's a derivative of
but for a kid in east l.a who almost
killed his teacher
now was i thinking about killing the
teacher no i was up on the
you'd call the second floor with an
aquarium and i looked down at the
teacher
and the teacher had pissed me off and
back in those days i wasn't the kind of
guy you'd want to piss off
so i dropped the aquarium and weighed 45
pounds
by the grace of god alaba he moved
and it didn't hit him in the head and
hit him in the shoulder and crushed his
shoulder right
clavicle if that had killed him back in
the mid 50s
i wouldn't be sitting here the queen
wouldn't give me anything not even a
postage stamp
and i wouldn't be living in a castle
because i would have spent the majority
of my adult life in prison
now i've got a special bonus clip from
dan and how you don't want to be the
smartest person in the room that i think
you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching another video to
taking action
here we go question number one what is
your big
dream number two how will you surround
yourself with greatness this week
and number three what's one good habit
you want to build starting today
jack welsh and a number of the guys say
the same thing
you want to be not the smartest guy in
the room
i have a lot of difficulty with that
because i normally am the smartest guy
in the room no matter how smart
everybody is
but you want to surround yourself with
talent and the reason why most
the kids don't surround themselves with
real super talent
is because they're insecure that these
people
these men and or women will extricate
you and sometimes they do extricate you
but as long as you've set it up properly
you're going to be extricated with a
bunch of money
a bunch of money
[Music]
if you want more dan pena check out the
last top 10 i made on him the link is
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there it's never going to get any better
than this kids
this is the eyes i said on youtube the
eye of the perfect
storm so i'm saying no matter what your
age is